So you know, I
think that there's
few things more primal than
the urge to communicate,
the pull towards intimacy,
towards merger with the other,
a way of almost
smashing, or isolating,
and debilitating sense
of individuation.
We feel so separate from
everything and everyone,
so alienated from ourselves
and from other people.
And this urge to communicate--
or as Terence McKenna says,
this urge to language--
is an ecstatic activity
of signification.
It is a way of saying we
are here and we exist.
It is a way of affirming
our own existence.
And through these developing
communication technologies
that started with crude
grunts as early hominids that
evolved into language and
ecstatic cave paintings
that eventually evolved into
the alphabet and writing,
it was this urge to telepathy,
to experience a technologically
mediated telepathy,
to share minds,
to share mind spaces
with one another;
and this is known by
David [? Porish ?]
as intersubjectivity and the
ecstasy of communication.
Intersubjectivity, like two
strands of DNA, human beings,
get coiled up in one
another when they have sex,
when they proclaim their
love with language,
when they take pictures and make
ecstatic paintings and compose
songs to put each other
in one another's world.
Perhaps the cinema is
the best technology
thus far to allow us to
share dream spaces together.
But this urge to
merge ultimately
is about a desire for intimacy.
It's a cry.
It's a manic,
existential agitation,
a desire to become one.
That is its origin.
That is where it comes from.
We are travelers,
[? hermonauts, ?] in search
of signification.
That, that is our condition.